タイガーしていくカップ理由今日は日本語で話ししたいと思うんですが
ios p japanese くっディア same フィルターカバー
metar browser voodoo ai perdu エスパーれスターズ
アップリング
seb cars bergere ユーザー me to do our ロビン
プロパティ
asapen us army air raid プロデュースわーわー
ano 症 pm psp クイーンズ japanese babe リングシェ
ブーバーれ
て進め in my mind ラウン to japanese cure
それじゃあ日本語でに今日私が話ししたいテーマはその英語会話というその英語を勉強
の一つのまあ
活動
の役割効果
どういうふうにその見るべきかというかそれについて私の意見を伸ばしたいと思うん
ですよ
まず
new ん
んではですね永劫会話とといくこれが日本のその英語勉強の2つのねー
非常に映像の応募な何ですか活動のようですよね僕の見て見てる限り
で英文会話というのはその英語会話をたくさんすれば
じゃあ流暢に英語を話せるようになりますか
私はそう思わないんですよ
なぜかというとうーんその後[ __ ]
かなりの程度のその理解度と
そして合意をとか
かなりのその英語の知識の持てる方ならばもちろんたくさん
もう話会話しなければならなるないですねそれだけの合意それだけの武器をこの
家中をするのはですね大事だと思うんですよだけれどもかなりの囚人がない
いい限りへ
後6人いわゆる英語会話というのはまあ3人とカーン後兄のですねええ
日本人と場合によっては英語ボッコボコくごとしての人の先生というかそういう人と
一緒になっていろんな話をするわけですよね
それがそれほど効果的じゃないんですなぜかというともう1時間が1時間でねそういう
ao 会話するパ
それぞれ話しするその機会が少ないと
そしてこの家9
その英語というのは他の勉強してる人たちのその英語ですからそれほど
喜久子の価値がないと思うんですよ
そしてたぶん自分が
その持っている合意その
これはへ
単語であろうがとりあえず野郎がですね
a 3一部しか使わないんですよ普通は
だからその
エイボン多くそういう言語内容というか3つ動画ですね
非常に低いんですよでそれよりももっとたくさん
スアの聞いたりいますそれはた地図もラジテーマですけれども
聞いたり読んだり処理ばいいわけなんですよ
でその1時間まあ1時間
それでそのいわゆるインプットの活動に
インポつにその
使った方がもなおさら効果的だと思うんですよ
だから一つの言葉を勉強するその戦略においてはですね
その五割 input ですね読む聞く
それが比較的良い安くできるだからそれをどういうふうに効果的にするかというのが
まず第一ですよだから興味のあるないよどういうふうにさといえば難しいものと割と
優しい
その内容とこ
いろんなバラエティに富んだその違った内容を聞いたり読んだり
場合によっては映画を見たり
どういう風にしてそのインプットの活動
おもしろ空港たっ効果的にするのがそれが第一
それによってある程度の数順になったらそれじゃあ今度
高レベルのその会話ができるようになればそれじゃあへ
誤解がを増やせばいいと思うんですよそれがあの呼ばですね
その言葉を勉強するのがですねそりゃなれという問題なんですよ慣れ
だから英語に慣れて来ないとダメなんですよ
でそのなれどういう風になれてくるかというとそれがたくさん聞いた
たぁくさん読んだりすることによって慣れてくるんですよ
限られたないよ他のその母国語でない酒盗と一生にいろんな
限られた話をするのがですねあまり効果的じゃないんです
でその日本語というのが構造的にヨーロッパ
英語の言葉と違うんですよだから私たち
そのヨーロッパ系との言葉をもとに日本語を勉強すると日本語のですね
構造に慣れて来ないとダメなんです
と同じように日本人がその英語をその勉強するときに英語の構造に慣れてこないとダメ
なんですよ
なっ例えば
よくね日本人が英語を話しするときにその
どうしようその一番後ろにつけるんですよ
トゥデイずナイスデイ just i ピンクなと思います
だけでも映画はそうじゃないんですよねだからこの構造そのものはですね大事なんです
よ
今僕がアラブ号とイランが fancy を勉強しているわけですよね
でイランの言葉ファンシーはですねこれ in 道をやる欧州
ヨーロッパ系統の a 言葉なんですよ
だから構造がそのヨーロッパの言葉
今英語なら英語とは人に言ってるわけですよ
あら部分はだいぶ違うんですよだからイランの言葉がはるかに勉強しやすいわけですよ
でその構造にですね
なれる
までには何時間も何時間を聞いたり
何千も何万何百万のちょの単語も読まないと慣れて来ないんですよ
だからメインのですね主なその仕事というか勉強するその時間はですねそれの方に
にええええその
使った方がいいですよで英語会話はそれで一つのも楽しに楽しみでいいと思うんですよ
そしてもうひとつはやはり
英語買い物に参加する時に自分がどこがその
まだ不充分じゃないっていうか単語が不十分じゃないとかそれが割と
うーんその目指すわけですよねだそういう意味では一つの刺激にはなりますけれども
しかし主な勉強の方法としてはあまり動けて気じゃないと思いますそれじゃ
の前がとー
the 4なら
[音楽]
ん
w